et avec nous pour en parler sur ce
plateau paul marie coûteaux directeur de
la revue le nouveau conservateur ami
d'eric zemmour bonsoir merci d'être avec
nous sur ce plateau paul marie coûteaux
à vos côtés aleksandar nikolic président
du groupe est reine de la région centre
val de loire président les jeunes avec
marine le pen bonsoir à vous pour nous
accompagner également serge coronado
conseiller en communication ancien
député écologiste bonsoir sergio
coronado merci également d'être là donc
on vient on entendra moins d'intérêt on
va revoir le sondage 1 que lors des
dernières campagnes présidentielles un
français sur deux qui a évoqué le sujet
de la présidentielle avec ses proches
dernièrement ça fait quand même peu
moins 10 points par rapport à janvier
2010 est sergio coronado est ce que on
peut vraiment parler d'intérêt où
finalement il y a beaucoup de
résignation devant des candidats qu'ils
suscitent finalement pas beaucoup
l'enthousiasmé chez les français
bonsoir merci de l'invitation c'est pas
la première fois que j'interviens sur
votre chaîne dont j'aimerais bien qu'un
jour vous prononciez correctement et non
le sheed tiens c'est celui que mes
parents m'ont donné je m'appelle
thériault ont fait thériault pour sa
part donné un prénom c'est pas grave
c'est pas grave mais comme je le répète
à chaque à chaque invitation c'est une
petite
j'avais raison
qu'on vit en ce moment c'est pas
simplement une question liée aux
candidatures où je dirais aux
personnalités qui sont en compétition
pour cette élection triomphale en
contact depuis de longues années en fait
une forme de désinfection à l'égard de
la politique
certains sociologues de nombreuses
études ont été publiées dernièrement le
monde en a fait même une page pas de
désaffiliation et notamment chez les
jeunes il se sent très peu concernés par
par la vie politique par les partis
politiques sont les interroger en fait
même quand ils s'intéressent à des
thématiques d'actualité comme l'écologie
et ben la crise climatique
l'effondrement de maisons et s'identifie
très peu très faiblement aux partis
politiques dont on dire en fait c'était
cesse d'être autrement des organisations
politiques et des partis dans leur
capacité à susciter l'intérêt à susciter
l'adhésion est par ailleurs on a une
campagne électorale est évidemment qui
peine à démarrer puisque le président de
la république qui est le candidat
il l'objet de toutes les attaques en
fait parce que c'est le seul qui a un
bilan à défendre
fait comme souvent dans le cas des
sortants utilise les moyens de l'état
pour faire campagne et tarde à se
déclarer donc prenez dans un entre deux
finalement qui amuse les commentateurs
et les plateaux de télévision en
invitant des candidats aujourd'hui en
rodage et le le panorama définitifs de
l'élection présidentielle la campagne
telle qu'elle aura lieu est telle qu'il
finira dans en
dans les bureaux de vote avec les pulls
pas les bulletins de vote dans cette
période là les
aleksandar nikolic vous avez le même
diagnostic que cornet d'eau notamment
sur les jeunes qui s'intéresserait pas à
la politique parce que c'est vrai qu'on
est assez frappé de voir qu'il ya
beaucoup de jeunes qui ont intégré les
différents partis politiques notamment
chez chez eric zemmour ou même chez les
verts on les voit régulièrement ici je
préciser dans les sondages d'opinion
s'est scellée marine le pen qui est
quand même donné en tête chez les moins
de 30 ans à peu près à égalité avec
emmanuel macron donc
quand on parle de l'électorat jeune mais
le vrai problème c'est que quand je
parle de marine le pen est donnée en
tête c'est évidemment parmi les votants
effet il ya un vrai problème avec
beaucoup de jeunes qui sont détournés de
la politique pourquoi parce qu'ils ont
eu peut-être à juste titre le sentiment
que pendant des années et des années
quel que soit ce qu'on avait pu annoncer
dans des campagnes chez les républicains
chez le parti socialiste ou ou emmanuel
macron il y avait une déception ensuite
il avait le sentiment qu'ils avaient pas
un changement majeur à la fois pour leur
vie quotidienne à la fois pour leur
avenir et et pour le pays lui-même qui
avait une espèce de long déclin cents
sans changement majeur il faut
évidemment refaire rêver montrer que la
politique peut changer beaucoup de
choses dans leur vie réelle et que c'est
pas juste du commentaire avec d une
analyse sur les personnalités momentanée
il faut redonner le sens premier de la
politique c'est à dire inventer des
idées pour demain inventé et faire rêver
j'espère que il
éliront marine le pen pour qu'on puisse
leur démontrer que ça ne sert pas à rien
de voter et que c'est important parce
que ça peut changer la vie or pour brice
teinturier directeur général délégué de
l'institut ipsos un jeu le site les
projets les propositions et bien ça
n'accroche pas il dit brice teinturier
on a le sentiment que tout glisse auprès
des français s'il n'y a pas d'éléments
suffisamment fort et structurant et dans
les personnalités non plus votre
réaction à ces propos paul marie
coûteaux quand on voit que votre
candidat avait fait une entrée
fracassante dans la campagne il
l'approché presque les vins bon sens il
était à 18% lors d'un sondage le 17
novembre là on va voir ce que ça donne
aujourd'hui emmanuel macron qui caracole
toujours en tête 1 selon un dernier
sondage et la suivit de marine le pen et
de près de valérie pécresse vient
ensuite seulement eric zemmour en
reconquête
12,5 pour cent
comment vous donc l2 frau 5% oui vous me
regarder bizarrement mais c'est en tout
cas ce que j'ai vu à 16 heures s'étaient
pas révélés candidat n'est pas rêver
aujourd'hui quand on gagnera blement
tout le monde oublie quelque chose c'est
que la désaffection
vient certainement de l'électorat de
gauche
qui est
pardon du terme un peu triviale largué
les candidats de gauche sont multiples
puissent ils sont six sept ou huit ans
ne sait plus rien
aucun atteindra le second tour chacun
s'y résigne de toute façon donc le tour
tout l'électorat de gauche qui a été un
peu le le show de la partie chaude de la
vie politique française que j'ai connu
moi c'est à dire dans les années 70 80
90 et démobilisé il ya plus de corps
minable de gauche
exception faite des manuels macro qui
est quand même plutôt à gauche qu'à
droite que je le vois une telle que son
passé sa politique en témoigne
contrairement à ce que l'on dit mais la
gauche dure et en démobiliser les
directeurs de cours je pense à autre
chose c'est tout et je crois que le
chiffre commenté votre votre analystes
tout à l'heure
de la désaffection
tient beaucoup à la désaffection du
lectorat gauche ou simplement voilà tout
le monde sait que ça se passe à droite
et je peux vous dire qu'à droite
l'intérêt est plus grands super temps ça
ne concerne que la moitié peut-être un
peu plus de la moitié des électeurs
sergio coronado vous êtes d'accord avec
ce diagnostic que la désinfection ça
concerne que la gauche alors c'est vrai
que la gauche et particulièrement en
difficulté dans cette campagne en tout
cas pour l'instant mais bon est-ce qu'on
peut parler pour autant d'un immense
enthousiasme à droite aussi
non moi je voudrais d'abord écarté en
fait les commentaires il m'a pas
beaucoup sur l'île enquêtes d'opinion
les sondages que vous dire mais
pas ou
non mais vous savez bien voilà
malheureusement la campagne et ont pas
passionnante on est bien obligé de se
baser sur deux trois chiffres
pardonnez-nous à la vente manque
d'originalité sur ce mois
d'août est en train de vous dire que
c'est peu dire que la campagne est
passionnant mais je vous dis simplement
de prendre avec beaucoup de pincettes
les enquêtes d'opinion
lors de la dernière élection
présidentielle françois fillon est élu
et et prix ont fait leurs élus et et à
la fin vous avez vu il n'a même pas été
finaliste aux élections donc moi je me
garderai bien cette histoire du mental
oui mais on est quand même à deux mois
de l'élection qui peut se passer des
choses d'ici là on ne connaît pas
l'ensemble des candidats on ne sait pas
qui aura les signatures d'ailleurs là où
je peux être d'accord en effet c'est que
l'ascension elle affecte davantage des
candidatures de gauche bref parce que
l'ascension concerne pour l'essentiel
électorat populaire je fais une remarque
également le ferait une remarque
également
sur les sondages qui ont été cités tout
à l'heure lors de la dernière élection
présidentielle en fait parmi les jeunes
en fait c'est jean luc mélenchon qui est
arrivé en tête à tête à marine le pen
s'est pas et est probablement cette fois
aussi
contrairement à ce qu'a dit votre invité
sur le plateau
[Musique]
dernières européennes yannick jadot
dernière présidentielle jean luc
mélenchon que ça ne vous plaît pas c'est
une chose mais fait des fesses et des
chiffres elle fait des gens qui ont voté
par les montages je pense que chez les
moins de 30 ans marine le pen ainsi chez
nous mais je dis que j'allais 18 seront
à l'élection présidentielle de 2017 -
marine le pen est arrivé en tête et
queue et que à l'élection européenne de
2019 marine le pen est arrivé en tête
chez les 18 30 ans vous confondez c'est
les 18 24 ans yannick jadot est arrivé
en tête il avait il a des difficultés
passées 25 je confirme ce que dit
monsieur la question la question est en
fait effectivement d'abord une campagne
qui accroche pas souvent fait les biens
ou par
les oppositions qui permettrait en fait
d'emporter l'adhésion de des débats
les jambois défilement aujourd'hui
comment se redéfinit le jeu alors
monsieur couteau a beau jeu de bloquer
un peu la gauche il a certainement
raison au fait des réalités à nombre de
couvertures à gauche qui me paraît un
peu un français enfin à droite vous avez
deux invités qui lorgne sur le même
terrain enfin je veux dire entre zemmour
et manu open n'a été si des droites et
l'autre de droite extrême en fait là à
vous pourriez en problème vous unir je
veux dire la braconne prévu chez les
élus de l'autre reprenant les mêmes
thèmes enfin soyez aussi lucie de
monsieur poteau sur eux le ridicule de
cette double candidature les trains
droite punissent désormais future
candidature est par ailleurs les
candidats de droite pour après
parce que c'est intéressant quand il
monsieur je vous vous défendez monsieur
jadot c'est ça
il était invité commentaires
parlementaire je défends pas
juste pour répondre parce que l'extrême
droite historiquement dans notre pays
ligue dans les années 30 watts et le
racialisme justement tout ce que nous
nous refusons on a une vision de
l'identité qui est spirituel derrière un
socle commun français pour qu'on puisse
vivre ensemble et à une histoire commune
une langue commune des valeurs en commun
et c'est tout l'un vers ce qui est en
train de remettre aujourd'hui en france
une gauche qui se perd et qui racialise
la société qui ramène à une identité
génétique et ça s'apparente justement
beaucoup plus à ce que à ce que
revendique en vrai l'extrême droite dont
vous êtes beaucoup plus d'extrême droite
pour définir l'identité dans ce pays que
ce que nous on propose parce que ce
qu'on propose n'est ni plus ni moins à
peu près ce que disait la gauche lors de
la troisième république c'est à dire un
vrai modèle d'assimilation français
historique que vous avez complètement
abandonnés et renier malheureusement
j'ajoute qui apparaît pour lui
paul marie couteaux avant de vous rendre
la parole de cette extrême droite en
france regardons l'histoire le stand
voisin pour la toute autre chose qui est
next à doite en france les antifas
commodités monsieur nikolic voit la
préfinale ni vous ni moi nous sommes
l'extrême droite et des bas sur
l'extrême droite on fonce alors je
voudrais que deux
gaullistes de gaulle a été traitée de
fasciste en 40 des 40 50 58 par la
gauche finit en 68 c'était
est-ce que ça va cesser les gaullistes
d'extrême droite surtout de donner votre
réponse à sergio coronado je voulais
rebondir sur ce que justement notre
invité disait tout le monde n'a pas ces
parrainages ça c'est bien vrai il y en a
un qui désert ça va rassurer personne en
tout cas ça va vous mettre d'accord tous
les trois c'est emmanuel macron lui tout
va bien puisque aujourd'hui le conseil
constitutionnel a annoncé qu emmanuel
macron avait bien tous ces parrainages
529 un parrainage d'élus pour l'élection
présidentielle c'est bon il peut être
officiellement candidat il peut y aller
loin devant les autres regardez là ces
chiffres
pécresse arrive ensuite avec 324
parrainage je vous laisse découvrir
cette liste un marine le pen trente cinq
parrainages pour l'instant ça dit quoi
ça selon vous sergio coronado
la course le parrainage a toujours été
difficile pour des partis qui sont
comptés de pater que ce soit à gauche ou
à droite donc il n'y a pas trop de
surprise dans cette affaire eric zemmour
d'avoir leur parrainage
je ne souhaite pas que l'extrême droite
ne
s'en laissait
pas de sarko un problème de démocratie
lollichon démocratie alors si vous me
donnez la parole et vous faites pas les
questions et les réponses à ma tâche
vous pourrez vous répondre puis entendre
que les mets le pied non mais attendez
attendez le système de parrainage est
telle que les filles les gens avaient
voulu changer et il aurait plus le
changer ça n'a pas été le cas donc il
faut un port parrainages de maires c'est
un fait c'est comme ça c'est le
fonctionnement la vème république il ya
des gens qui arriveront à la voir
à la fin est ce que vous me demandez si
je traitais que marine le pen s'était
que eric zemmour n'est pas le parnasse
non je ne verserai pas une larme de
matam pour le fait que l'un ou l'autre
de ces deux candidats qui sont à pau ne
puisse pas à la fin je trouve que leur
vie des dames ont répondu et relayée
déjà
il y aura certainement des doutes il
faudra choisir donc et et que par
ailleurs
l'étonnante et on ne te bats lacombe
bien d'avoir fait qu'on a mis les patins
feront tous trois âgés dire on peut lire
les qualifie tels qu'ils sont qualifiés
depuis des dizaines d'années vous êtes
des candidatures c'est un droite ou de
droite extrême on a l'impression pour
les accès aux connaissances ce n'est pas
le cas en ces qualifications tout à fait
politique vous avez une histoire par
exemple aux autres candidats défendent
petteni que présente pétales comédie on
défende pur les juges de france contre
toutes les évidences historiques et vous
monsieur vous est donné à n'importe quoi
là arrêter cette logorrhée
vous développez
helvète a été condamné pour les entendre
donc voilà
vous avez invité tous les trois pour
commenter un petit peu les règles à
camden mais c'est vrai que ça tourne à
une batterie à quoi la gauche
des idées que
j'ai pas pu finir tout à l'heure oui
enfin bon dos j'essayais d'être long
j'ajoute tout de même que si les
français sont table qui peut prévenu
contre les élections c'est parce qu'ils
ont l'impression que ça sert à rien et
ça c'est pas de notre faute c'est pas la
faute de la droite j'ai mené la campagne
avec philippe de villiers d'autres après
philippe séguin du reste dont j'étais un
collaborateur prétendument fasciste
certainement pour ce monsieur
contre la constitution européenne le non
l'emporté très largement nous étions
ensemble chers amis bien sûr et les
français ont quand même écopé d'un
traité européen qu'il venait de refuser
ils ont ensuite voté pour une succession
de candidats j'irais même jusqu'à
parler de chirac et sarkozy mais surtout
hollande et maquereau qui n'ont
absolument pas tenu de baratin dont il
les avait abreuvé pendant la campagne
comment voulez vous que je chantais soit
pas prévenu contre la politique avec une
classe politique qui si c'est vrai c'est
à droite comme à gauche c'est ce que je
viens d'ailleurs c'est ce que je viens
de dire ça si vous prenez chirac ou un
homme de droite mais enfin bon
d'ailleurs je trouve que c'est vraiment
anormal que des candidats comme marine
le pen qui est aujourd'hui donnée au
second tour à 18% proche de l'emporter
donné à 46 % au second tour ou jean luc
mélenchon parce que moi je suis ouvert
et démocrates ou jean luc mélenchon qui
représente un vrai courant qui est
donnée à peu près à 10 % dans les
sondages soient en difficulté pour avoir
des parrainages alors qu'ils
représentent une grande partie de la
population qui puisse pas se présenter
c'est une anomalie il faudra vraiment
réfléchir pour que tous les courants qui
représente une vraie partie de la
population puisse se présenter
démocratiquement si mélenchon n'est pas
candidat et votre peau
aucun de vous trois n'a dit voilà la
campagne ne débute pas tout simplement
aussi parce que peut-être que emmanuel
macron lui ne ne se dévoile pas pour
l'instant en tout cas officiellement il
s'est d'ailleurs exprimé sur le sujet
interrogé là-dessus un tous les jours
les journalistes tentent leur chance sur
ce sujet écoutez emmanuel macron dans
une interview accordée à la voix du nord
je ne peux pas raisonnablement expliquer
aux français que je vais m'a donné à ce
temps démocratique important alors que
je leur ai dit que je serai président
jusqu'au bout et que nous avons une
crise à la frontière ukrainienne qui
menace notre sécurité collective
la situation n'a jamais été aussi tendue
qu'elle ne l'est aujourd'hui les heures
que nous vivons sont décisives pour la
sécurité de toute la région alors il
prend de la hauteur à la crise
ukrainienne emmanuel macron c'est
finalement assez commode pour lui sergio
coronado
bref et en travers de la vème république
c'est à dire que les gens qui contemple
have
bénéficient et
[Musique]
bénéficier des moyens de l'état pour
faire campagne je veux dire qu'on a fait
le le rappel des différentes élections
payant celle la plupart des présidents
sortants qui se sont représentés
conjoncture en fait ça peut être le cas
de françois hollande ont retardé
jusqu'au dernier moment pour se déclarer
candidat on savait défendre dans l'arène
ça veut dire défendre un bilan peut-être
souliers aux critiques alors que quand
vous avez un président en exercice et on
le voit avec emmanuel macron ont
bénéficié d'une couverture médiatique
que son contradiction au bénéficie des
moyens de l'état pour faire campagne
on bénéficie en effet d'une
situation tout à fait particulière très
protégé alors que quand on veut être
candidat à l'élection présidentielle un
candidat ou une candidate déclarée
finalement vous êtes l'objet de toutes
les critiques de tout et remarquons on
regarde vos propositions on les critique
on les décortique ce n'est pas le cas
aujourd'hui des manuels machine nous
avait déjà fait le coup quand il était
ministre de l'économie il avait
bénéficié des moyens du ministère de
l'économie pour initier sa campagne
élyséenne alors ça pose en tout cas le
problème le cas légers tout à l'heure
nous nous décrivez un de plus en plus de
voix s'élèvent pour critiquer le fait
que du coup il n'y a pas vraiment de
débat notamment avec les autres
candidats gérard larcher était le
premier parlé de problèmes démocratiques
d'ailleurs les français aussi 1 75% des
français se prononcent pour que le
président participe à un débat lorsqu'il
aura annoncé sa candidature
vous êtes d'accord paul marie coûteaux
ça pose vraiment un problème
démocratique ce manque de débat avant le
premier tour
je suis mal placé pour en parler parce
que j'ai parié j'espère que celui qui
j'ai parlé m'ont oublié que emmanuel
macron on est un bilan catastrophique
qu'il serait pas candidat je me demande
s'il n'est pas perdue au pari pour tout
finir
je trouvais que muller était
catastrophique et surtout d'ailleurs une
fois il faut
ajouter un point important sur ce sujet
jouera pas avec qui il pourra gouverner
si par malheur
pour lui les candidats et si pas mal gré
pour le pays il est élu parce qu'il aura
pas de majorité donc c'était un
président de la république il sera
enfermé à l'utiliser en train de
chercher
chaque jour une majorité pour faire
passer ceci ou cela parce que elle elle
même va être balayé quant à son
entourage de pas le cap bon c'est quand
même bizarre le rayonnement qu'il est en
train de tenir il ya une crise en
ukraine une crise on ne craint pas la
première fois qu'il y en a à mon avis
elle est très sûr loué par les
démocrates américains qui ont un
problème de politique intérieure mais
passons il y aurait bien des choses à
dire sur le sujet je ne fais pas trop il
fit doctement mais
enfin je ne me risquerai pas mais il
pourrait très bien dire parce que ça
c'est une vraie crise qui se profile si
en mars ou en avril un état islamique
s'installe dans le sahara grosse crise
cette fois graves pourraient très bien
dire j'annoncerai ma candidature au mois
de mai déjà 2 juillet à dire si une
crise internationale n'empêche d'être
officiellement un candidat
ça veut dire que il ne sera jamais
dans l'acquis et tutelle je vois pas
très bien quelle attaque si ils
cherchent pour pouvoir annoncer sa
candidature
c'est puéril et ça fait partie du
personnage c'est à dire des mots qui
n'ont pas de sens
votre jeu évidemment il faut qu'ils
puissent participer au débat qui
participe aux débats pour que qu'il ya
un échange sur les différents projets
qui peut y avoir mais au moins si ça
permettait
à
asseoir une autorité française à la fois
dans la crise ukrainienne à la fois au
mali vous en parler mais moi c'est ça
que je trouve grave en fait c'est que il
se donne une posture de grands chefs
d'état mais il dit là dans la craie et
crise ukrainienne c'est bon j'ai eu joe
biden et on va se coordonner en réalité
ça va être juste un ambassadeur des
états unis on est le vassal des
américains ce qui est mais vraiment et
et dans l'histoire et dans et quand on
voit au mali justement il dit qu'il
prend le temps pour ça et donc en
incarnant la france on voit que notre
ambassadeur et virait on perd beaucoup
d' influence dans cette zone
géographique notamment avec les russes
qu'ils sont arrivés récemment avec des
djihadistes qui gagne du terrain après
quand même 53 français qui sont morts je
crois
je trouve que on n'arrive pas du tout à
s'affirmer il essayait de presse de se
faire passer maintenant comme un le
président des européens
quelle est la position aujourd'hui en
quoi il a contribué à une puissance même
collectivement évidemment je préfère que
la conserver une souveraineté française
et que la france soit puissante mais il
ya ce conflit le crédit aux portes de
l'europe on n'a aucune influence il y a
a absolument aucune projection
pour l'europe sur tous les sujets qu'ils
soient économiques dans l'économie du
futur qui se tint moi je suis très
inquiet pour le futur et je trouve que
ça serait bien qu'on puisse en parler
que lui puisse en parler en débattant
surtout qu'il montre son incapacité à
faire rayonner la france dans tout les
temps toutes les
ce que je viens d'évoquer que ce soit en
ukraine roumanie sans oublier des
claques nombreuses l'australie la
turquie enfin la
frontière j'ai juste concentré sur les
dernières derniers jours la desserrer
longue est exactement mais c'est si on
fait le bilan sur cinq ans la l'espagne
à la longue on va laisser le mot de la
fin à sergio coronado je sais que voilà
vous avez eu râler sur les sondages mais
enfin ils n'ont pas cher est mêlé le
micro est toujours le grand favori
aujourd'hui de cette élection pour vous
on peut justement avoir des surprises
ont d'une certaine manière et c'est
parfois ce qu'on entend parmi les
français en sincèrement ce duo bonne
façon c'est plié emmanuel macron va
l'emporter vous est de cet avis sergio
coronado ce sera le mot de la fin
non je construis campagne n'est jamais
gagnée tant que le vote n'a pas eu lieu
je pense que le peuple est souverain
donc titulaire il décidera de son destin
je crois par ailleurs qu' on est encore
loin de la campagne en elle-même en fait
c'est que par exemple les débats étaient
sans doute une des explications du refus
des manuels ma croûte de se prêter à
l'exercice
jauron un rôle en fait on avait constaté
dans le débat de l'entre-deux-tours
l'impréparation l'incompétence de marine
le pen a présidé la france ce qui avait
valu en fait tu dois peut-être même
d'une partie d'une partie de l'extrême
droite il tant de désaffection et de
remise en cause qui explique aujourd'hui
par exemple que les cadres du rnd se
sont plus représentés par pas réglementé
qui rallie la candidature de cet ancien
collègue sur ses news donc je prends en
effet qu'il faudrait attendre le dernier
mois de la campagne pour voir en fait
quelles sont les propositions en jeu et
comment au fond descendu de son
piédestal emmanuel macron aura la
capacité il a à défendre à la fois un
bide en pietà en effet assez assez
négatif et puis à se projeter et à
apporter des propositions ces
différentes de ce qui l'a mise en
application ces dernières années je vais
juste et serbes ont exaucé nikolic qui
en rêve est sur le départ parce que
c'est ce qu'elle a fait des progrès si
jamais elle rend elle affronte une
nouvelle fois
ce que
marine le pen revient d'un salon par
exemple à la rencontre et j'ai lu un
article sophie de menthon qui disait que
ce n'était pas la même qu'en qu'en 2017
que c'était d'ailleurs la candidate la
plus précise la plus sérieuse
et elle elle a beaucoup travaillé pour à
la fois sur les sujets des sujets
cruciaux comme le référendum sur
l'immigration qui va redéfinir notre
identité sur la sécurité sur le pouvoir
d'achat immédiat on a un projet
absolument complet sur tous ces sujets
et je pense que ça va convaincre les
français lors des débats je veux juste
finir pour juste barria un petit mot
comme le faire eric zemmour avec des
citations pour notre ami appelée marie
coûteaux mais je dirai juste une
citation qui me qui me revient les
petits esprits parle des gens les
esprits moyen des événements les grands
esprits des idées c'est une citation
d'eleanor roosevelt et on comprend
pourquoi la gauche en est là parce que
depuis le début monsieur n'a fait que
critiquer les autres macron parce qu'il
utilise les moyens d autres il les a il
insulte les autres d'extrême droite ou
je ne sais quoi il remet en question la
gauche quelque part sur d'autres mais
absolument aucune proposition aucune
idée depuis le début est encore une fois
ça explique pourquoi la gauche et danses
des arbres alors c'est vrai que ce
n'était pas un débat pour avancer les
idées à la décharge de sergio coronado
mais voilà pour parler de la campagne
même si il ya eu de l'affrontement
notamment sur le clivage gauche droite
on s'en est rendu compte merci en tout
cas à tous les trois ça on adore la
prochaine fois sur le plateau est comme
ça voilà on aura vraiment
merci en tout cas à tous les pros
d'avoir été l'apport pour ce débat ou
merci